raph database is really another whole
side of no sequel databases that is
pretty much unrelated to any of the no
sequel databases I've discussed so far
and what a graph database really is it
is exactly what it sounds like it's a
way of querying vertices and nodes along
a graph in a really efficient way so if
you think about problems such as
traversing a social network this is the
problem that like any problem can be
solved relationally but it becomes
unwieldy after a certain point in time
and so what a graph database is as a way
of very conveniently asking those kinds
of problems and getting answers for
those kinds of problems in a convenient
way for your application well and our
DBMS is essentially a relationship among
tables so if you think about how what a
graph is a graph tends to be a an
arbitrarily connected set of points so
if you wanted to represent an arbitrary
an arbitrary set of points and how they
connect in a database you typically
choose one table and then describe the
relationship between rows in that table
which means joining again and again and
again further out you want to explore in
that relationship it's something that
can be done but becomes extremely huge
in terms of the problem especially if
your graph is heavily connected so we
tend to use graph databases for two
kinds of problems one for trying to
determine you're trying to move along
your social network trying to find
friends of friends and friends and what
they might be interested in and also we
use it for various types of proximity
algorithms trying to find a best
possible match for you as a person or
the best possible product or
relationships between products for
product advisory services these kind of
databases are extremely useful for
constructing algorithms like that one
last area where they can come up a lot
is in a data visualization there's a lot
of different types of data where it's
not entirely obvious how things connect
together and a graph database allows you
to sort of probe the connections between
things and follow them in real time a
graph database is really a different
kind of beast than the other no sequel
databases graph database is obviously
very good at quoting a graph and
interpreting a graph any of these
databases can do it but if you think
about what the document databases are
doing and the key value stores are doing
they're functioning in large measure to
distribute things across a cluster of
servers a graph because it's by its
nature arbitrarily connected means that
it's fairly difficult to solve that
problem in the abstract across a network
of machines so graph databases with some
exceptions but tend to focus on on
problem sets that can be constrained in
the size of one machine so on some
levels you know some no sequel databases
besides graph databases particularly
document databases also work perfectly
great in a single on a single node a
single replicated node that a single
node because it's so convenient to
develop against them but it's a question
of what are you trying to develop if
you're trying to develop something like
an application that saves different
kinds of data and then searches by it a
document database is often an extremely
convenient way to perform that whereas
be trying to probe relationships between
things especially relationships that go
beyond sort of an immediate set of
neighbors a graph is a better choice